hello everyone
welcome to this video tutorial on er
diagram in dbms by simply learn
in this session we will learn about ear
diagram
starting with what is an er diagram and
why it's been so much used by the
companies
then we will learn about the symbols
used in the ear diagram
and get familiar with the components of
it so hey everyone
i am abhishar abuja from simply learn
and welcome to this video
on er diagram in dbms but before we
begin
if you love watching tech videos
subscribe to our channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update let's start
have you ever wondered how these big
ecommerce companies manage their tons of
data that keeps updating every second
and these datasets keep on updating in
their databases
to perform operations on this data they
should have a conceptual understanding
of these databases and this is done by
understanding er diagrams of the
databases
so let's understand what an ear diagram
is
an entity relationship diagram describes
the relationship
of entities that needs to be stored in a
database
er diagram is mainly a structural design
for the database
it is a framework made using specialized
symbols to define the relationship
between entities er diagrams are created
based on the three main components
entities attributes and relationships
let's understand
the use of er diagram with the help of a
real-world example
here a school needs all its student
records to be stored digitally
so they approach an id company to do so
a person from the company
will meet the school authorities not all
their requirements
describe them in the form of year
diagram and get it close checked by the
school authorities
as the school authorities approved the
ear diagram the database
engineers would carry further
implementation
let's have a view of an ear diagram
the following diagram showcases two
entities student and course
and the relationship the relationship
described between
student and course is many to many as a
course can be opted by several students
and a student can opt for more than one
course here
student is the entity and it possesses
the attributes
that is student id student name and
student age
and the course entity has attributes
such as course
id and course name now
we have an understanding of er diagram
let us see why it has been so popular
the logical structure of the database
provided by air diagram
communicates the landscape of business
to different teams in the company
which is eventually needed to support
the business
ear diagram is a gui representation of
the logical structure of a database
which gives a better understanding of
the information to be stored in a
database
database designers can use er diagrams
as a blueprint
which reduces complexity and helps them
save time to build databases quickly
ear diagrams helps you identify the
entities that exist in a system
and the relationships between those
entities
after knowing its uses now we should get
familiar with the symbols used in ear
diagram
the rectangle symbol represents the
entities
oval symbol represents attributes a
rectangle
embedded in a rectangle represents a
weak entity
a dashed oval represents a derived
attribute a diamond symbol represents a
relationship among entities
double over symbol represents
multi-valued attributes
now we should dive in and learn about
the components of er diagram
there are three main components of fear
diagram entity
attribute and relationship
entities have weak entity attributes are
further classified into
key attribute composite attribute
multivalued attribute and derived
attribute
relationships are also classified into
one-to-one relationships
one-to-many relationships many-to-one
relationships and many-to-many
relationships
let's understand these components of
fear diagram
starting with entities an entity can be
either a living or a non-living
component
an entity is showcased as a rectangle in
an er diagram
let's understand this with the help of
an ear diagram here
both student and course are in
rectangular shape
and are called entities and they
represent the relationship
study in a diamond shape let's
transition to
weak entity an entity
that makes a lines over another entity
is called a weak entity
the weak entity is showcased as a double
rectangle
in er diagram in the example below
the school is a strong entity because it
has a primary key attribute
school number unlike the school the
classroom is a weak entity
because it does not have any primary key
and the room number attribute here
acts only as a discriminator and note of
primary key
now let us know about attributes
attribute
an attribute exhibits the properties of
an entity
an attribute is illustrated with an oval
shape in an er diagram
in the example below student is an
entity
and the properties of student such as
address
age name and role number are called its
attributes
let's see our first classification under
attribute
that is key attribute the key attribute
uniquely identifies an entity from an
entity set
the text of a key attribute is
underlined in the example below
we have a student entity and it has
attributes
name address row number and age but here
row number can uniquely identify a
student from a set of students
that's why it is termed as a key
attribute
now we will see composite attribute
an attribute that is composed of several
other attributes
is known as a composite attribute and
oval showcases the composite attribute
and the composite attribute oval is
further connected with other roles
in the example below we can see an
attribute name
which can have further subparts such as
first name
middle name and last name these
attributes with further classification
is known as composite attribute now
let's have a look at multi-valued
attribute
an attribute that can possess more than
one value
are called multi-valued attributes these
are represented as
double oval shape in the example below
the student entity has attributes phone
number
roll number name and age out of these
attributes
phone number can have more than one
entry and the attribute with more than
one value
is called multivalued attribute let's
see derived attribute
an attribute that can be derived from
other attributes of the entity
is known as a derived attribute in the
er diagram
the derived attribute is represented by
dashed over
and in the example below student entity
has both
date of birth and age as attributes here
age is a derived attribute as it can be
derived by subtracting
current date from the student date of
birth
now after knowing attributes let's
understand relationship
in er diagram a relationship is
showcased by the diamond shape in the
ear diagram
it depicts the relationship between two
entities in the below example
student study course here both student
and course are entities
and studies the relationship between
them now
let's go through the type of
relationship first is
one-to-one relationship when a single
element of an
entity is associated with a single
element of another entity
this is called one-to-one relationship
in the example below we have student and
identification card as entities
we can see a student has only one
identification card
and an identification card is given to
one student
it represents a one-to-one relationship
let's see the second one
one-to-many relationship when a single
element of
an entity is associated with more than
one element of another entity
is called one-to-many relationship in
the below example
a customer can place many orders but a
particular order cannot be placed by
many customers
now we will have a look at many to one
relationship
when more than one element of an entity
is related to a single element of
another entity
it is called many-to-one relationship
for example
students have to opt for a single course
but a course can be obtained by number
of students
let's see many-to-many relationship when
more than one element of an entity is
associated
with more than one element of another
entity is called
many-to-many relationship for example
an employee can be assigned to many
projects and
many employees can be assigned to a
particular project
now after having an understanding of pr
diagram let us know the points to keep
in mind while creating the ear diagram
first identify all the entities in the
system embed all the entities in a
rectangular shape and label them
appropriately
this could be a customer a manager an
order an invoice a schedule etc
identify relationships between entities
and connect them using a diamond
in the middle illustrating the
relationship do not connect
relationships
connect attributes with entities and
label them appropriately
and the attributes should be in our chip
assure
that each entity only appears a single
time and eradicate any redundant
entities
or relationships in the ear diagram make
sure
your er diagram supports all the data
provided to design the database
make effective use of colors to
highlight key areas in your diagrams
with that we have come to the end of
this session i hope
it was exciting and informative if you
liked it please let us know in the
comment section
also do subscribe to our channel and
stay tuned for more from simplylearn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here